[Musique]
lait de coco crème fraîche citronnée
voilà ça va nous réchauffer
glacial ce sera pas trop et on va
poursuivre ces informations insolites
alors avec une performance dans le vide
ça va se passer samedi à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux il sera question
d'ageline de slackline je compte sur
vous pour détailler
sur une sangle qui fait 2,5 cm en
général c'est sur une longueur de de 4
mètres et quelques et la secte c'est au
sol enfin c'est pas tout à fait au sol
mais c'est pas d'accord et après il y a
des des viandes c'est pas des déviantes
des variantes merci
des variantes à la slackline notamment
la highline et là Highline en fait c'est
la même chose mais très très haut je
crois
notamment la balade dans un paysage de
montagne par exemple voilà sur un
glacier alors là c'est tellement haut
qu'il faut une sécurité donc un baudrier
en général permet de si on tombe de
passer écraser au sol et donc il va y
avoir un événement à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est samedi
après-midi de 14 à 18h une initiation
donc pour démarrer la slackline et aussi
une démonstration qui sera faite par un
champion qui s'appelle Lucas Giovanni
Moreira qui est le recordman mondial de
la plus longue traversée en 2021 donc là
pour l'occasion il va
surplomber survoler enfin bref traverser
l'éco-quartiers sur une Highline de 110
mètres tendu entre deux grues à 40
mètres de haut
quartier qui est en train de voir le
jour petit à petit à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à proximité de
cette nouvelle guerre de la ligne 18
donc si on lève les yeux au ciel on aura
cette personne grue vous verrez Lucas
Giovanni Moreira en train d'évoluer et
sinon si on verra tous pour l'initiation
à la slide un petit peu plus basse donc
voilà samedi et on va terminer avec un
défilé mode un peu spécial qui va se
dérouler à Versailles j'ai l'impression
que c'est d'occuper votre weekend
Grégory donc samedi c'est fait voilà et
dimanche alors je vous encourage à vous
rendre à la mairie de Versailles parce
que c'est un événement partenariat avec
la mairie de Versailles c'est Alison
Laurent qui est une styliste qui est
spécialisée dans l'Obs cycling
l'obsideling c'est en fait
prendre des des objets et les
revaloriser les transformer mais en
mieux toujours en mieux évidemment une
veste pourrie aux manches mettons troué
vous enlevez les manches vous en faites
un gilet enfin voilà c'est c'est un peu
ça le principe alors elle a décidé elle
a une boutique depuis une boutique
atelier depuis 16 ans Versailles et elle
a décidé Alison Laurent sa boutique
c'est kentukraine elle a décidé de
d'organiser des défilés donc là c'est un
défilé collectif de mode éco-responsable
et vous me dites d'accord parce que ça
suffit
alors vous aurez collectif donc ça veut
dire plusieurs ça veut dire des
créateurs de d'accessoires de bijoux et
de vêtements c'est dimanche 14 mai 15h15
et quoi d'autre et bien c'est un peu une
alternative à la fast fashion voilà
la consommation de vêtements à outrance
neuf bien sûr est-ce que dit Alison
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de de bonnes
créations attendez parce que je fais la
maligne je cherche mes phrases et je
vais faire
la meilleure création est celle qui ne
nécessite pas de matière neuve voilà on
fait une belle phrase pour terminer
cette petite chronique donc voilà on a
une idée pour aller manger l'idée pour
sortir samedi et une autre idée pour
sortir dimanche est-ce qu'il y a une
idée qui a retenu votre attention manger
manger
on avait déjà vu ça à 50 ans en Yvelines
juste à côté de l'immeuble de TV 70
justement on avait relié effectivement
la line entre l'immeuble de TV 78 et
celui de la Bibliothèque Universitaire
de l'UVSQ donc voilà ça c'est à voir
samedi et du côté de voisins Bretonneux